it's official after many soulful
performances with fierce choreography we
have finally crowned a winner on season
2 of the masked singer reminder if you
haven't watched this is your cue to turn
away we have many spoilers ahead now if
you have watched please stick with
Charlie and me if you're still watching
you are acknowledging that I am about to
tell you who won one more time I'm about
to say the name of the contestant who
won the show this is your last chance to
please turn away are you ready I'm ready
drum roll please this season two winner
of the masked singer is the Fox
welcome to our aftershow finale I'm
Deidre Behar and I'm Charlie O'Keeffe
yes things were extra foxy tonight on
the finale take a look at the epic final
unmasking
[Applause]
Wayne Brady he's the coolest boy Wayne
Brady
I am so elated for him I think this
story has been such a brilliant one that
we've watched unfold throughout the
course of the season not only is he a
true talent a Renaissance man who can
sing dance act really do it all but he
was so candid about his journey and why
he wanted to do this and strip away the
pretense and just be me and show the
world my talent and now we've been
saying Wayne Brady from the start not
always in the correct way originally
thought he was the thingamajigger
but after that we soon realized he was
our Fox and now our masked singer
champions I'm so proud of him I'm all
about it and I am happy for the Fox but
everyone knows I was pulling for a
certain Rottweiler who ultimately came
in second place take a look
what's up dodge tree it's my American
Idol Chris Daughtry : for him to see how
do you feel
I mean SIA is shaking those vocals were
absolutely insane it's the club we we
want now we can we get that we got that
one um I thought it was awesome he
definitely had a story he hasn't really
been in the limelight lately so I think
this was a great comeback for him and
I'm excited to see what he has next
hopefully some new music 100% I mean
this is a guy who is I think it's really
refreshing to see a star tell us I felt
like I was having a rut with my career
and this show really reinvigorated Andry
inspired me I can't wait to see what he
does next year it's gonna be really
awesome all right we got Wayne Brady we
got Chris Daughtry and up next it's my
girl the Flamingo we finally found out
who was underneath all those fancy
feathers
[Applause]
it's a girl I know I got emotional
watching this I fit you and me but we
weren't friends as kids but I know we
were in different parts of the country
really loving w the Cheetah Girls she is
she is such a nice person I've been
fortunate enough to interview her a few
times throughout the years she is
someone who just treats everyone with so
much kindness respects your name she
gives you a hug she wants to know your
story so I think it was incredible to
watch her story and you watch her on TV
I know you worked on the real you you
watch her and you think this girl is
just her life is so glamorous and
everything is so perfect and she's
letting you know I had self-doubt I felt
vulnerable she said I was told I'd never
amount to anything that's like really
insane because she is truly so gifted
and I thought it was funny after her
unmasking she's like well I didn't know
people liked me singing this much maybe
I'll give it another shot which I am hi
hoping she does yeah we're here we're
totally asking Adrienne Bailon Houghton
for new music in 2020 because this
wasn't enough exactly an all season I
have been calling out people who we
assumed were on the mast singer and then
later addressed saying they weren't on
the mast singer but ended up being a
singer so I'm excited to see her address
this on the real hopefully after their
holiday hiatus we're gonna come back
with those three well well Deidre
everyone knows you were rooting for the
Flamingo but we do want to respect and
acknowledge how much you rally for the
Leopards yes I did let's watch just how
many times Jeter was spotted talking
about her beloved leopard aka seal I
stand seal we know I say it loud I say
it proud I am such it's like nerdy how
much of a seal I really love respect
let's be honest of course seal recorded
a version of that song in German he is
that talented he can see you different
languages kiss from a rose it's like the
soundtrack to my childhood you are the
biggest fan
correct what was pointing to seal here
for you so many things please do not
cancel seal I've Los Angeles chapter
president of the seal fan club it is my
humble honor to introduce the leopard
who I still believe is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all I know is Alec Baldwin's taking some
I think Joel McHale baby onto something
Alec Baldwin he's got like we also said
goodbye to the leopard
everyone please send Deidre your
condolences how are you feeling she's
not okay well I know it's been a full
week since that happened and you had
this same exact moment so how are you
doing tonight
I still not well I was really pulling
for seal as you just watched he's been a
very part very big part of my life and
my musical journey I love him so much I
think he had such a fun experience being
on this show
I just I'm gonna I'm gonna cowbell do
you wish he had taken home the golden
trophy mask oh that's interesting I
think he definitely could have he has
the talent the poise the charisma all of
that but I'm so happy for Wayne Brady I
think any of the the power trio that
made it to the top three could have
taken it but the leopard you know I got
your back and if there's a guest judge
spot next season seal seal
I'm also agreeing well that's hot we
need to have a seat right there next to
dr. Kennedy oh well it's been a fun
season all along and we have been
guessing the celebs that are under the
mask but we will be the first to admit
we weren't always right and by we I mean
Dedra I'll own it I mean sure I had some
wacky guesses guys but can you blame us
those clues were really tricky take a
look I started to piece together this
has got to be Wayne break completely do
you think it's Wayne Brady I think it's
Wayne Brady I've seen him on Broadway
actually in kinky boots when he was in
that about two years ago I recognize
that voice 100% I started to think
comedian actor they said it's someone
who's sick of playing second fiddle so
immediately my brain goes to Martin
Short henna set on Martin Short and for
the moment until we get more clues I'm
saying Martin Short as well I'm said I'm
Martin Short third yes first things
first my brain immediately went to Bow
Wow
so just the immediate dog parallel my
brain at this point has shifted from
bow-wow and I'm now on to rage a
love lucy' Chabert and she is my best
guess because she is a fixture on the
Hallmark Channel she does some of the
Christmas movies and of course who could
forget the jingle bell rock scene from
Mean Girls
I had Candace Cameron Bure or Melissa
Joan Hart down there as well I'll be
honest I thought it was Naya Rivera at
first if the Black Widow mask isn't
Scarlett Johansson I'm gonna be so angry
I would love to see Scarlett Johansson
on the show again
I don't think she's doing it I think
she's a little bit listen I was thinking
Bret Michaels okay the red bandana
talked about a health scare which we
know Bret unfortunately went through so
rosebud that's the name of the fan base
for amber Rose's fans and I know she's
from Philadelphia where Temple is
located my brain went to two people Rose
McGowan and Kathy Griffith my best guess
is still somebody whose quote
Christmassy like a Lacey Chabert or
possibly even this week I started to
maybe think a Lea Michele for a second
thought Amy Sedaris oh that's a good guy
yeah the cooking the food at home with
Amy Sedaris obviously she has as well
yeah I found some clips of her singing
it doesn't quite sound like her voice to
me though Wow Wow I think my favorite
part was Bow Wow's Gus hey it made sense
at the time
dog dog the parallels look they were
they were creative they were very
creative we certainly went through a few
names there yes well the good news is
that the mass singer will be back on
February 2nd who would you want to see
compete listen there's a lot of people I
would love to see I definitely guessed
more towards the Broadway genre you love
your Broadway star my Broadway stars
Wayne Brady look at him there we go on
Broadway I'd love to see idina menzel
maybe Billy Porter his name was thrown
around a lot this season even someone
like Rosie O'Donnell I think would be
very entertaining to watch
well you mentioned Adina Rosie I want to
see a woman wind XC is respect to the
guys t-pain Wayne Brady you guys are
awesome but like I'm here for like team
lady and I'm also all for High School
Musical of course a High School Musical
stay on like where it's the biggest so I
would love to see anyone from that cast
I don't know if we'll get Zach but maybe
Vanessa ashley tisdale someone along
there Corbin blue blue let's get you
guys on the show um okay for me we go
back to my 90s loving heart I
immediately think boy band girl group
from the Backstreet Boys I'd love to see
mclean talked about like a
larger-than-life personality who they've
gasping multiple times maybe have
guessed him he's got young kids it's
like a recurring theme on the show that
people want to do it to impress their
kids and it's a show they can all watch
together of course I was a Spice Girl
Stan as a child I think I don't know if
we're gonna get necessarily Victoria
Beckham but I think Mel B who's got like
again a larger-than-life personality and
Baby Spice you know Emma Bunton we've
seen her on TV in the last couple years
and she's got a killer voice I think
they both bring so much energy and
charisma to the stage I know you Stan
High School Musical
I loved Glee I think we need some Glee
folks on this show do you agree I agree
I could see some I don't know if Lea
Michele is gonna happen I know you've
thrown him out there before but there's
plenty of others yeah
Naya Rivera Chris Colfer Heather Morris
I would love to see it and putting them
out in the universe definitely helps let
us not forget season one when Sherri
Shepherd's name was thrown around a lot
season two we got Sherri Shepherd right
and the same thing happened with Wayne
Brady exactly so it's like you guys the
more we tweet about it and talk about it
and put it into the universe happen oh
my god a Spice Girl moment a Backstreet
moment we have the Cheetah Girls well
maybe Sabrina Bryan more Cheetah Girls
Girls Williams I love it uh who do you
guys want to see let us know your picks
and the good news is that Fox has
actually started teasing us with some of
the costumes for next season check this
out
[Music]
[Music]
sefa season 3 of the massing howdy
costumes ready the costume you picked is
very appealing I got its place
see you after the Super Bowl
special delivery from Fox for season
three can we get a little cow about a
little cowbell for those cops oh my
goodness it's bigger and better truly
than before I have a lot of questions
okay the banana I want someone singing
hollaback girl by Gwen Stefani maybe
even Gwen Stefani spelling banana in the
banana costume I love that idea but keep
dreaming she's a little busy but
nonetheless it'd be awesome maybe
Rachel's Oh banana was her tagline that
small dog Beverly Hills Paris Hilton for
sure my mind also went to Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills star Lisa
Vanderpump the queen of Beverly Hills
and all thanks pink and fluffy and
amazing we saw like a female looking
monster costume master season 1 t-pain
could the female version be someone who
knows t-pain has worked with him in the
past um I thought it was interesting
that we saw that like cowboy yeah so you
know my brain automatically goes to
Billy Ray Cyrus I think he'd be
incredible I think his name out here
wants the seasons I'm sorry I'm throwing
it out again cuz I want to see it and we
definitely saw that large box with
another costume which we didn't get to
see on a football field right I mean
it's airing after the Super Bowl I'm
thinking there's gonna be some big star
athletes oh that would be insane cuz we
saw Antonio Brown we obviously had
Victor Oladipo this season athletes are
incredible to me because it's so
unexpected exactly you know they're
known for being rough and tough and for
being super athletes it and just
hyper-masculine you know what I meant
like but to see them really embracing
the arts and to see them on stage and to
belt it out like that it's always just
like a fun moment and when they have a
voice like Victor Oladipo
all right we're blown away and we would
never guess that in the first place
which is crazy I love it but I have to
ask if you were to be casted on the
masked singer
what would your costume choice be I'll
admit I thought of this a few times yes
what I'm driving late at night this is
what I think of I'm a huge foodie I
automatically go to two things I'd be a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich or I'd
be a chocolate chip cookie
we saw ice cream so these aren't out of
the question why not as long as there's
lots of as you guys can tell there it's
a recurring theme I love sparkles and
glitter as long as my costume is
drenched in sequins
I mean sign me up on that a sequins
cookie costume
thank you I'll take it I like that I'm
gonna sign on the dotted line how about
you um I'm tall so I'm gonna play on
that I think I'm gonna go with the
giraffe like a fun glamorous giraffe on
the massacre a glam giraffe it's perfect
well it has been a wild ride this season
and we are so excited to take even
deeper into season three I'm not gonna
lie I'm probably gonna have some
withdraws from guessing with you over
the holidays sure sure I'll text you and
thank you keep the thoughts going but
before we go we do need to clear up a
few things guys I want to let you know
for the record officially Charlie does
not and has never worn lipstick if he
did we would celebrate it you know I
love I love a full glam I love a full
beat but Charlie just doesn't wear
lipstick the truth is he's just gifted
with beautiful lips and we have great
lighting in this studio so special
thanks to Charlie's chapstick our
amazing production team for this amazing
we got the comment every week we just
had to say yes I'd also like to point
out that a lot of you seem to think we
have interns who do everything for us
now we would love that we don't have any
we'd we'd love to have someone be our
invite but DJ and I do all the work and
the guessing just like you guys at home
every week we are looking on Google
Wikipedia and everywhere in between and
as you saw the guesses aren't always
exactly correct I mean you saw a lot
more with more with me yes all right
we'll take the victories we take the
failures it's all ours exactly we're
really stoked for next season guys I'm
Deidre Behar and I'm Charles E O'Keefe
Happy New Year we'll see you in 2020
more cowbell
[Music]
you